my question for you is this
being here in Florida yeah taking this
entire conversation that we've had yeah
the beautiful weather the freedom a
system that's working right flourishing
getting rid of all the things that
you're frustrated with right could a
good liberal like you
vote for a guy like Ron DeSantis
all right we are at the newly revamped
local Studio look at that warm wood in
the background we heard your calls warm
it up guys and we did here we go the
brand new local Studio the brand new
brand new local Studio I'm still
old-fashioned Dave Rubin and I am joined
today by my friend
philosopher author can I still call you
you're a teacher of some sort your
friend and friend of the show and friend
of the show that's what you said when
you sat down more importantly than
anything else friend well no it's
actually not more importantly our
friendship is the most important thing
and yes it's nice to be a friend of the
show well it is good to see you my
friend people gozian obviously uh you
have not been on the show since February
we just checked this February of 2019 so
quite literally four years ago this
month right it's been a while a lot to
catch up on but what set that we we
booked this thing a couple weeks ago
right and then last night was the State
of the Union Address right so let's
start let's start let's just start with
that because something interesting
happened and I referenced it on my show
this morning on my wrap-up show that
what I see happening in America that I
think is one of the most disturbing
Trends is that we're all watching the
same script we're all watching the same
movie yeah and we are experiencing
wildly different things we are seeing
completely different things our
reactions are completely different
anyway I'm watching that thing thinking
this guy's a liar a fraud he's obviously
drugged these people are bringing in all
of the wrong policies it's a miracle he
hasn't fallen off the stage and knocked
the podium over I mean all of all of the
stuff and then I'm looking at your
Twitter
and you're seemingly impressed by what's
going on and you seem to like him you
seem to think that it's put to bed some
of the questions about his mental Acumen
etc etc dementia and then I thought man
I cannot wait to sit with Pete tomorrow
because we're friends and it does not
matter if we disagree on this stuff but
but how we could view this so different
right
now and so the other context of that is
you're texting me like are you drunk
tweeting yeah well I thought you must be
drunk or you were hacked right because
you're going bite and seems sharp this
all makes sense so I so the I guess the
the more profound point is that we can
disagree about our perception we're
going to talk about what we perceived
but we're still buddies I'm still
sitting here we're gonna hang out like
that there's a context for our
disagreement so this is so this is what
I thought independent of the content The
Narrative that Biden is senile or he has
dementia I think that speech to me it
completely put that to rest he was sharp
he was focused and I understand he has a
teleprompter I understand he has notes
in front of him
a senile person or a person with
dementia I don't care if he's on
monafidil what provision whatever drug
he is on I don't think he could have
delivered that performance now I'm
talking independent of content okay so
let's put content aside we can talk
about that sure so we'll do the content
and the policy thing after but putting
that aside so you're just talking about
his physical and mental ability to walk
up on that stage and read that prompter
you think that look I can't diagnose him
yeah for sure he has dementia or
Alzheimer's or something but to me he
clearly clearly has something wrong with
him and that the fact that they can prop
him up either through Adderall or a ton
of coffee or God knows what they have
whatever those drugs are I don't know
how do you view that and go well because
he had a decently cogent two hours that
overrides all of the other video of the
stammering and confusion okay shaking
hands with ghosts and things that made
me question okay two things let's take a
one step back the thing that changed my
mind about Donald Trump yeah was one in
his in Trump's second debate with Biden
he clearly destroyed him in fact
sometimes I think Megan Kelly and I are
the same person she tweeted something
like it's all been an act because up at
that point I almost never heard him make
a coher current argument or sentence or
statement wait when you're saying he
destroyed him you mean Biden destroyed
no Trump in the second to second okay
there were only two because they
corrected the first one was the first
one was not that good
but then I thought like you can't go
from nothing to that like you can't go
from a a rambling incoherent ignoramus
to that I mean he was on that I think
any objective independent Inquirer would
have looked at that debate and say Trump
so I think with Biden
so so this gets back to the question how
can two people look I think any
independent person would look at that
and say
he was on point it was a good talk he
was clear he does not have senility he's
not suffering from senility he's not to
dementia his points are well articulated
he wasn't slurring and I realized that's
a low bar
okay so some of the words weren't
articulate or enunciated perfectly but I
I walked away from that and I questioned
a lot of the narratives I also think
that there is a kind of unfairness no
matter who's in office you know you when
Biden uh pin the the and I gave blood or
something on his granddaughter people
edited it to make it look like he was
touching her breast or I think that
there's a lot of just
um hacks who if they don't like the
content and we can talk about the
concert that's right we will and I'm
just talking about him standing up there
and delivering that performance I don't
understand how you could not look at
that and said drugs aside
say that was that was a he was on point
I was a good talk he was clear he made
arguments he remembered to the extent
that he's on a teleprompter he was
looking around he engaged people in real
banter uh I thought it was a great talk
okay so I'm gonna content to the side
through this content right so first off
I would say that a we don't know what
the drug situation is so I would imagine
and I don't know enough about cognitive
the drugs that they prescribe for
cognitive decline or whatever but it
seems to me that you could basically
take almost anyone probably unless they
were at the real end of stage with this
stuff and make them cogent for two hours
so that I don't see how that puts it to
bed if anything it seems to me you're
saying there there probably are drugs
out there that can make you okay so that
would be the question to find somebody
right again this is coming from a guy
who has brought up an ethical violation
several hoax papers right uh you know by
the way if I prefer that you hide in a
way he is still the pilot of the plane
right so whether I agree with the stuff
or not the guy is in charge of an awful
but hoping that that I'm right doesn't
make it right like you you would have to
find people who suffered from similar
perceived cognitive ailments and give
them whatever Suite of drugs and see if
they could perform I I I I would highly
doubt it unless you want to say he's
somehow like a trick pony he somehow and
even this is territory I'm not
particularly comfortable wading into
he's somehow performatively giving a
talk he has no idea what he's talking
about but even then it was pretty
impressive I just thought it put to bed
to rest the idea that here's a senile
demented guy now now if you've watched
the videos of Joe Biden from 20 years
ago I mean he's clearly a different man
I mean it's just I'll give it to you 100
but that talk I thought he shined you
know it's interesting because I I also
spent I had two grandmothers that both
had a certain amount of dementia yeah my
my grandmother on my mom's side had it
for longer and I and I really saw and I
spent a lot of time with her because I
was doing stand-up at night so during
the days I was with her often for days
on End hours and hours and I really saw
that decline one of the things that I
noticed that Biden seems to have and
I've seen a lot of people mention this
also is uh there's a dysregulation
related to his emotional response you
yeah so at times he seems very slow and
quiet then he does that whispering thing
and then out of nowhere he starts
yelling oh well you don't know why about
China yeah and that China thing where
he's yelling it's like there was no
anger to be expressing there but he he
has to emote in a very weird way because
something back there isn't all right
again I'm not a doctor it could be a
performative thing too though right I
mean it could be like this is almost as
if it's broken down and it's not
performing correctly right like well it
wouldn't be
as if he wouldn't doing doing it
correctly if he broke down and had
random outbursts but if he has outbursts
about the same thing but again I don't
even think that was an outburst I think
he was trying to drill home something
maybe even to appease the Republicans I
don't know right the funny thing is
neither one of us know what he was
trying to drive hold on related to the
content part of it okay so putting that
aside because I I don't want to spend
three hours talking about his cognitive
state but I think the fact that we even
don't really see that eye to eye is
interesting that that you just feel it
was enough evidence as you said to put
it to bed where to me it was like that's
not enough evidence to put a bed it's
enough evidence to go oh I'm probably
right about this thing and we will
probably find out that I'm right right
and you know what I mean like look at it
if he makes it through the term at some
point when he's no longer president or
or if he's had to step down or saying
it's all going to come out he's
obviously on something right so so my
main takeaway for that was different
than yours I think my main takeaway is
that we are so divided and I've lost
very close friends of mine who have been
in my house you know buddies of mine
over political disputes we've lost
co-friends co-friends yeah cool friends
so so the fact that you and I can
disagree on this and be completely cool
like that's the model right like that's
what everybody should be striving and
who ultimate look dude if you if you
said listen my kids are sick I know
you're in Florida for a few days David
can't do it can you help me out dude in
one second I'd be there yeah so like and
does it matter to me if you think Biden
is a dribbling fool no it doesn't matter
to me it's actually more interesting in
a way because we're all going into our
own Echo Chambers whether we like it or
not it's becoming increasingly hard to
do it so because I know you as a person
and as a decent human being and all that
to to watch last night and I'm watching
you tweet and I'm like right this is
wild but it really made me want to sit
down so all right so let's talk a little
bit about the the content right of some
of this stuff I don't think of you as a
purely political beast but you sort of
became a political Beast because of what
was going on at Portland State and you
stance on free speech so maybe for
people that haven't seen our previous
interviews or don't know too much of
your bio you want to maybe hit like a
minute or two of that just so that it
has a little context uh a little context
to how you started talking about
politics yeah so I experienced a woke
takeover or let's put it this way I
experience an authoritarian takeover
fueled by an ideology not only for which
there's absolutely no evidence but for
which the evidence was against every
time I started asking not even
questioning but asking for evidence the
Hammers came down the investigation
started so you were an assistant
professor of philosophy philosophy we
did an event very early on in my career
Christina you brought Christina Huff
Summers and I to Portland States and
remember the SWAT teams the security
guards they were everywhere we had to go
in the room and they were like shielding
us that was the first time subsequently
it's happened all the time now but that
was the first time I had ever done an
event where security was needed where
there were protesters outside people
screaming there were threats of violence
cops everywhere I remember we had to go
to a separate green room where the cops
then had to escort us to the stage all
these huge Shields that were like in
case someone shot us yeah yeah I
remember that yeah but the point is you
you were an assistant professor of
philosophy right a lefty a liberal right
liberal I was never a lefty okay so you
were liberal in in the classical sense
of liberalism but that was not good
enough for a place it was not good
enough it Not only was not extreme
enough but it wasn't good enough because
to question the Orthodoxy means you're
not just wrong you're bad yeah so enough
enough about about that did the hoax
papers Etc then you'd write you wrote
These hoax papers with uh James Lindsay
that really caught fire and basically
the whole idea was to show how the
peer-reviewed process is is
ideologically corrupt right we wrote the
conceptual penis yeah should we joke by
far and everyone went crazy about it was
a hoax paper they said you know this is
you guys didn't prove what you thought
he did to prove it you need to do a b c
d e we did a b c d e did anybody say oh
my gosh you've done a b c to E I guess
we were wrong no instead they say
bagosian's unethical for fooling all
those Journal letters to take deranged
papers because your point in doing it
was to show how nonsensical so much of
these studies are studies that
ideological corruption these are the
musings of ideologues they discharge
their moral impulses and journals we've
got to clean this up like there's just
no question but instead of saying like
oh geez you know maybe certain
disciplines we have problems we need to
be more rigorous no it's attack the
people saying that there's a problem
okay so to relate that to the political
part of this state of the union and some
of the stuff that we didn't see eye to
eye on which I think is it's Rich that
that we're doing this so my basic
position is that virtually everything he
said was either a lie or or an
intentional obfuscation of the truth
something like saying gas prices are
going down that is technically true but
they're significantly higher than when
he took office or inflation is going
down technically true okay significantly
higher than what he took office we can
get into some coveted stuff in a bunch
house but what would you say about that
General okay and by the way I'm not just
blaming this on Democrats okay so let's
say that you're right okay let's say
that 100 of everything you just
articulated to me is correct yeah
wouldn't the best way to convey that to
be have Sarah Huckabee gave the wouldn't
it be to just go through those points
and say
Biden said this here's the actual data
it's not true it doesn't have to be
complicated you know Ross that's
precisely by the way what we did on my
show today that that's what we did on my
day that's what people do when they
participate in a similar framework of
rationality and reality yeah I didn't
see that at all in her I know did you
watch I did I did okay so she's talking
about Trump and narratives and story no
no you take if you believe that Biden
says not you but if One Believes the
Republicans particularly believe it then
in the the retort to that speech you
just go by you go that was like a canned
prepared right so you wanted something
written on the Fly basically which I
agree I agree probably would have been
this is what he said this this is just
not true and the American people need to
know why it's not true like the American
he said he's going to trim the death the
debt by by two trillion dollars the
whole thing about the police was
completely insane yeah so so I would
much rather have prefer forget what I
would have preferred if you want to to
talk about things that are true and
participate in reality then that
follow-up talk that I can't remember
what the rebuttal or whatever yeah that
should have been data driven and talked
about where Biden was wrong and it did
not okay so and it was a terrible missed
opportunity so I will say and I said it
on my show this morning I thought her
the speech itself I thought was quite
good because I think she was dealing
with the grand narratives I liked her
mind I agree I liked her line on you're
basically either for reality or for
craziness something to that effect but
yes she didn't go in they clearly didn't
write it on the Fly because then they
could have done what I did on the show
this morning or Vivek ramaswamy could
have given a great talk whoa capital I
mean he could have done that right okay
let's say her let's say it was flawed or
well let's just put that aside for a
second the rebuttal because because very
few people actually watched the rebuttal
in a case like this someone like you who
cares about truth when you hear him say
these things if you're willing to grant
me the the leash that what I'm telling
you right now is true that gas prices
for example oh he came in we're about 2
30. they went up to five now they're
around 3 30. so they are higher than
when he took office and then he says
they're coming down it's a complete it's
just a verbal trick now I have no doubt
Trump did it I have no doubt Obama did
and everything else but I think
something's happening now where the lies
because of covid
are so everywhere in society and they
have been so uh debunked in real time
right that that people can't take it
anymore something feels different about
The Lies We can be lied to to a certain
degree and I think we're we're crossing
a threshold with the lies that is going
to do something very dangerous something
like that so so what are you asking then
so what I'm asking you is when you when
if you can grant me that what I just
told you it's true about gas prices and
inflation that it is true inflation was
here when he got into office then it
went here now it is down a little so his
argument eight percent right his
argument is that it's down but it's like
no it's not down from when you took over
it's down from the peak of it over the
sun and the implication of that as its
causal the key caused it right there's
some some policy position or the fed or
something which is also dangerous that
they think as political beings and as
presidents that everything that happens
is because of them which is also
nonsensical right but what I'm asking
you specifically is in terms of the
manipulation of truth that they're all
constantly doing what do you think think
we do with that
boy that's a fantastic question you know
I think that's one way to bridge the
liberal Conservative Republican Democrat
divide is just stop denying reality I
mean one of the things that jumped out
at me in that talk and I don't know if I
think you've had Heather McDonald oh
many times yeah she's gonna come out in
a couple weeks yeah okay so she's great
at this Matt Thornton has a great book
The Gift of violence about this when he
was talking about the police and the
role of the police with young black men
yeah I mean that was just so contrary to
what the data is since George Floyd
homicide rates among among black men
have gone up 50 in my own city of
Portland Oregon they've gone up uh well
over 200 percent and that's another
story I'm happy to get into it but
that's another story together
um death from by young black men the
number one cause of death is other young
black men and that's the only true for
those quote unquote racial groups and so
I think denial of reality and not
stating thing
we need to be blunt about facts and
evidence and not couch them in political
terms now when he talked about you know
whatever his value systems are and how
you can solve the problem that's another
thing but to blame the police for this
or to say that the police are causally
then you know I can't remember exactly
how we frame and that's just
not only is that it's false that's just
a complete denial of reality well not
only is it in denial of reality but I
think he does it as a bit of cover
because he can't lose his radical base
okay so that's that's a political okay
so that's the thing you need to signal
to your base and so I think that there
so I lost just just as a sign I lost a
thousand followers on my tweets last
night which I thought was kind of funny
I hope I got you I hope I got one or two
for you when I was kind of making money
yeah no I just kept laughing about it
because you know one it's good to not be
ideal captured by your own audience sure
audience capture but the other thing is
I I think if you're not willing to cross
the line and say look if somebody does
something not everything Rhonda Sanders
if you're a lefty does is bad or not
everything but so many people they're
just not willing to cross the aisle and
say look this is true or this is false
um and you know Harris was up there you
know clapping you know robotically
clapping at these idiotic things that
are clearly divorced from reality I
don't know
in a two-party system
what the solution to that is given the
penalty for crossing the aisle Andrew
Yang and others have suggested well that
there is no solution you have a third
party
Etc I don't I don't know
I don't know what the solution is but I
do know that the environment is so toxic
right now for even saying you agree or
not only even that platforming going on
someone's show just talked to Brian
Keating this morning uh you know even
going on someone's Show when he did the
prayer review videos and the grief
people have gotten uh from that that the
left then won't have you on because
Constantine kissing is another example
I'm another example I used to be able to
go on all sorts of things I owe you an
apology by the way oh why is that I'm
gonna apology maybe you should say this
off no no no no do it on there you know
you you used to tell me that you know
this whole Shadow Banning from Twitter
and stuff and I'm like oh dude please
come on like but it turns out it was you
were completely right like it was you
was you were telling me all along and
I'm like you know I wasn't thinking it
was a conspiracy theory but now you know
Jack goes before calling you basically
lied he lied he lied I hope they get him
for perjury he lied under oath as well
as we're taping well the thing is and
what his lawyers will get him out of and
why no one ever goes okay in college
exactly they didn't need to it was a
linguistic trick they never called it
Shadow banding what did they call it
they called it uh what do they call it
guys D something it was de-escalation
yeah visual filter oh yeah or contextual
filtering something like that so they
were just playing with language
constantly well that's the other thing
everybody does is bamboozle everybody
through language the woke people are
particularly the will crowd are
particularly good at that they just
Bamboozled people so okay so I have a
feeling we probably have less
disagreement on some of the policies
than than may we may even think but on
the race one yeah specifically and that
moment where he talked about how you
know when you get pulled over black and
brown people my children never had to be
told right that they had to keep their
hands on the wheel and blah blah it's
like I was actually told that yeah
that's what I said on my show this
morning my dad said the first time I
went out driving with my Dad we went to
uh HB Thompson Middle School parking lot
to go drive out there is because there
you know it's big area I could drive and
before I even started doing anything he
said he said David if you ever get
pulled over you keep your hands on you
called you David yeah he called me David
he still calls me David you keep your
hands on the wheel and the fact that
Biden went out of his way to racialize
that totally so and also black and brown
the implication being that somehow this
is 100 million people and it's just so I
don't know if you have you had Wilfred
Riley on your show no I met him a few
times
and stuff I mean fantastic what a shame
that we have to live in a society where
I have to say to you well he's a black
activation like that shouldn't have
literally anything to do with it but he
has some some should I tell you about my
black friend Larry Elder right feel
better right see right so we don't
that's the other that's the other kind
of point of commonality what should we
do is we can we should be able to agree
that there's a truth of the matter
independent of whatever immutable
characteristic you possess right so if
we can't agree to that then there's a
just we're in I mean it really isn't
commensurable at that point but
um the fact that we consistently
racialized this is a problem but here's
here's my pushback on that
because so many and I do that thing for
my YouTube channel where I go out and I
ask random people questions yeah and I
put them on a line from you know neutral
to strongly agree and strongly disagree
and they walk to the side what do you
call that by the way Spectrum Street
epistemology yeah so we're going to link
to the channel below Street epistemology
from my first book obviously in Eastern
Europe is it better to be rule it's
better to be ruled by the USA than
Russia or the USA than China all kinds
of questions homosexuality abortion
trans everything yeah but consistently
one of the things that I find in that is
when I talk to black people not
African-Americans but black people
they are they're pissed and they're
they're deeply they're not even deeply
concerned they're they're worried
they're fed up and I think we need to
have an honest conversation like is that
imaginary like is that are those
concerns they have how rooted in reality
are they and I think well which concerns
are you talking about when you make the
distinction you said totally not not
African-Americans are you talking about
when you're in Europe well well people
for example who just have dark skin okay
so in Europe for example if they're not
they're not African-Americans because
they're not Americans right right so but
that's one thing I consistently find is
that they are mad they're frustrated
they don't know what to do and I think
we need to have like some kind of an
honest Town Hall debate that isn't
captured by lunatics for what is the
nature of like what are these I don't
like to use the word grievances because
it's so fraught but what are the
perceived problems and what can we do to
help people and so what are you hearing
as a perceived what would be that
someone's angry but I mean I can go
through the list of watching MSNBC and I
know what Joy Reid's screaming about but
yeah give me what like an average versus
they don't have the same opportunities
that uh white people have and I think if
you look at the demographics of school
systems and the funding of school
systems they're right but I don't think
it's on racial Arts I think it's on
economic lines and then the the mode if
you will the distribution happens to be
that poor more poor people are black
than white is a percentage of the
population but I I think it starts we'd
also have to talk about why that is
because more black people were educated
and in two parent homes until the
welfare state in the early 70s
forever correct so so it has a lot to do
with the Democrat policies not just in
imagine not just that the system is
inherently right right so how do we get
Beyond how do we speak bluntly about
facts and evidence without having the
Democrats go berserk or the Republicans
go berserk how do we just say listen
these this is the data we we need to
make the best available the best
policies based upon the best available
evidence without people losing their
freaking Minds like I don't know and
well I do have a theory on that no go
ahead I mean it's what we're doing here
in Florida
which is we have a highly competent
government that is run by someone who is
clearly articulating what their beliefs
are and when they try to bring crazy
Trends gender identity into schools nope
we're not going to do that when they try
to connect woke ideology to
African-American studies no we're not
going to do that we're not going to let
a place like Disney with zero tolerance
for madness yeah and so I think that
that actually is the only answer I don't
know at a societal level a Country-Wide
level I don't know that that yeah sort
of scale that or at least from the top I
guess my concern is and I haven't been
following that closing my concern is I
would want to make sure that no speech
would be quelched in that process so if
you want to have someone spouting
some idiocy like critical race Theory
that's fine and I know I have
significant disagreements with people on
this
you know I I think I initially said you
know you wouldn't have people if someone
wants to you know scream about phenology
about the Earth being 5 000 years old
but these are dangerous divisive toxic
and racist beliefs there's also a
difference between talking about them
and teaching them yeah you can talk
about the Nazis you wouldn't want to
teach Nazi ideology correct and testing
people in terms of the right ideas that
students that answered back right that
Accords with the ideological precepts so
I'm I'm concerned about that I haven't I
have so you gave me your solution I'm
going to give you my solution so my
solution is burn the whole thing down my
solution is that we need to build new
things we need to build new institutions
so this I'm going to burn a tremendous
number of bridges when I say this I'm
just going to tell you because I'm an
engineered a speaker you're in a burning
mood I'm I'm in a burning I've been in a
burn mood for quite a while now but I
um and I don't mean burn them down
physically of course I mean let them
fall into further delegitimizing
themselves because they're they're not
legitimate basically you're saying give
them a push they're on the way so every
single attempt at saving them or
fighting for free speech or this guy got
canceled because he showed a picture of
the Prophet Muhammad which by the way is
on Wikipedia that now certain countries
don't want on and if you look at the
Islamic Wikipedia still if you go to the
museums in Turkey there are uh drawings
of the Muslim Prophet Muhammad but
bracketing that for Assad as an aside
any attempt to fix or solve the problem
is only slowing it down the problem
cannot be solved we have tremendous Dei
bureaucracies we have people who have
jobs for life we have College of
Education that are the worst of the
worst
we have to build new things we have
University of Austin Ralston College
Peterson is building a new platform
that's the solution to this problem let
let them just fall into what let them
get what they deserve well a I agree
with that I had Stephen Blackwood in
that very chair talking about Ralston
and he's obviously doing that with
Jordan what's happening here in Florida
now with Chris Ruffo is going to sit on
the board of I believe it's new school
on the west coast and they're gonna
try to fix what's going on over because
even in Florida our institutions were
captured by this stuff too how important
is it do you think I mean as someone
that you care deeply about Academia I
mean how important is it that kids even
go to college at this point
I think the well let me just back up
saying wokism is a universal solvent it
will destroy everything and anything it
touches and so I'm incredibly
sympathetic to having a zero like the
hungarians have they zero policy there's
like we're letting none of this in like
zero yeah so the best answer to your
question is what I told my kids you know
my kids uh I told my daughter who wants
to go to college don't do it be an
electrician
oh that's the other thing I tweeted last
night we need to be talking more about
vocational that education absolutely
vital what did your daughter say to that
she entertained it but she wants to go
to college and I I can't say it I'm
disappointed like I will do you know I
want her to live her life and pursue it
my parents paid for my education
although at the time it wasn't an
ideology meal but I I think uh my advice
to to young kids would be
and it's not to go to a conservative
University like Liberty the the solution
to this stuff
to ideological capture is not to create
institutions that have the opposite
ideology the creation the solutions to
create new institutions that are
truth-based that have genuine
intellectual diversity so uh my my
suggestion would be to send your kids a
vocational vocational school yeah it's
interesting on on the Liberty Front I'm
only mentioning this because I was
invited there I spoke at their Sunday
convocation yeah 14
000 kids huge huge absolute fourteen
thousand uh they know I'm married to a
man they know as I still describe myself
but begrudgingly pro-choice there's a
couple other things that I certainly am
not a traditional conservative on right
Standing Ovation from these kids spent
the entire day walking around the school
taking selfies with kids yeah I want to
give you a hug for that but we're on
followers I think Lindsay was the only
person who was an atheist who's ever
been invited to speak before so what
what does that tell you then about the
conservative even in this case and you
as a guy that wrote a book called
Emanuel for creating atheists you spend
an awful lot of time around religious
people now awful
so your primary allies seem to be from
what I can tell Christian conservative
correct and sort of more I don't know
people from maybe a more nationalist
political Camp certainly than than you
consider yourself from or something like
that people like Mark Andrews and who
just basically think that the system is
corrupt like I do and I need to build
you know that's the new culture War by
the way Legacy institutions versus
building new things old Universe like
sub stack versus New York Times Wall
Street Journal Etc okay locals perfect
100 new things that's well you're a
builder I lost the threat of the
conversation what so well this odd
Alliance that you're now in as someone
that was right that you were literally
your mission at first at least at one
time was to create atheists I also do
want to talk about how the atheist
movement has seem to be collapsed but
let's pause on that for a second so that
your allies are now the people that you
maybe used to wanna convert yeah so I
think while I've never converted anyone
I just gave them the tools to convert
themselves just to be clear so I think
that this cultural War 2.0 is very
different from 1.0 and I published a
piece in this in the American mind years
ago but excuse me it's
we're unified in objective truth that
you can figure out what it is that you
can find it we're unified on the Rules
of Engagement so the Rules of Engagement
is if you if someone gives a talk and
you don't like to talk you don't blow a
bull horn at the talk like they're
irrational civil ways to adjudicate
disputes you know legal mechanisms
framework if you don't like the statue
here in Miami I don't know some in
Portland they destroyed a deer statue
right you you go through Democratic
means and have I mean I couldn't care
less what statues are there but you
don't take the law into your own hands
to quit Judge Judy uh so so there's an
agreement that there are mechanisms that
we can go to to figure out how to solve
civil issue civil disputes so that's the
other thing right so are you shocked
though even at this point even though
we've been if people go back and watch
our videos from six years ago yeah uh
they'll find us talking about these same
things me from a more Lefty perspective
as well but my point is are you shocked
that there's virtually no liberals
obviously not none and Omar is doing it
and I know you know two or three others
yeah but what you're talking about are
no they're liberal principles not
defended by liberals that's correct
that's correct and I think that what
conservative and liberalism shifted but
I'm going to suggest a new access to you
the new access is and um Andrew my
friend Andrew our friend Andrew Doyle
wrote about that book in his book the
new Puritans the new the axis of the way
to think about these problems isn't
liberal conservative right left it's
authoritarian non-authoritarian and the
most important thing is cognitive
Liberty we have to enable people to live
like in London they're arresting people
for praying I mean I think anybody
should be able to talk to themselves
anywhere they want if I want to talk to
myself it'd be a lot if I started
talking to myself right now right now
the idea the idea that you would arrest
somebody for that you have a group of
people the woke people the dominant
moral Orthodoxy who wants to tell you
exactly what to think and if you don't
think it you're a problem right that we
we need some kind of a struggle session
we need to somehow correct this we need
to intervene we need to have you know
government and sponsorship programs
interventions I suggest the access in
the culture War
is best thought of as authoritarians
versus not right so basically there's
there's authoritarians or Libertarians
not meaning you're a Libertarian card
caring member of the libertarian party
but you you either want control or you
don't want control something yeah and
you want to let I want to let people
pursue whatever lives they want to lead
I I think the same thing but so you
acknowledge that that that that is far
more rich on the right or the
conservative side of the aisle now right
I will acknowledge that the left has a
terrible problem
that is not that is Unthinkable among
traditional leftists that it's been
prosthetized by wokeism it's been
proselytized by an invasive ideology I
wrote about that in my first book
um that is not inherent in the left and
you know it's guilt by association it's
not even guilt that I'm here it'd be
like somebody else won't talk to me
Zello you've been untucked I've been on
Tucker Carlson twice so you won't run oh
you were on Reuben's show you well so
what like
so yeah there's no question that there's
a tremendous problem with that so it
seems to me that the inmates are running
the asylum on one side and there is
another side now that is doing basically
what you're asking that perhaps you have
some political disagreements with and as
as I kind of went through I think those
things will just kind of become less and
less over time I think that's just the
natural entropy of it but what would you
say is a problem what do you see on the
conservative side now I'll just fully
look I'm married I'm gay so there are
obviously traditional religious
conservatives that are not thrilled with
that for sure to be sure and yet I have
found most of them to be the most loving
Pleasant interesting decent people on
the planet I've probably even add
supportive to that yeah
yeah so so what would be something that
you're seeing as a red flag on that side
that you're like oh this is where you
guys are just absolutely getting it
wrong this is where you're where I
cannot vote for the same people that you
vote for I'll tell you a few things uh
we'll bracket the gay marriage thing
um and it will bracket the Ukraine thing
because that's another thing I know
that's another can of worms yeah uh in
terms of domestic policy I would say
it's one of the reasons I still consider
myself well I'm consider myself a
classical liberal is I believe every
citizen every person born in this
country has certain entitlements I
believe that they're entitled to a
public education or the first rate all
of John Rawls I believe that they're uh
up to age 18
um they're entitled to at least two
square meals a day I don't think people
should be discriminated against
educationally in terms of their zip code
or where they're from or their color
their skin or their religious beliefs
um but hold on I just had a pleasure
because I'm not sure what conservative
believes in anything else they may not
want it's fun to certain things through
the government okay well you get okay
then I'll I'll tell you the other
substantive disagreements let me just
say real quickly let me then I'll put a
a pin in that I also believe that that
includes health care for people up to 18
possibly 21 is a compromise I don't
think anybody should be sick or dying
because in this country if they're a
citizen uh if their parents can't afford
adequate Health Care from them insulin
which Biden uh uh discussed
um so I think that's one of the things
that separates me and you see so you it
seems to me that just to I want to just
clearly get it so it seems to me you
still believe that the state
has some role in education and in health
care and and you feel that the
conservative side or the Republicans
just simply don't believe that on the on
the school choice one that you said
there where that you want them to choose
that's clearly a republican
okay I'm talking about funding of K-12
education but there's a guy on my board
National progress Alliance and
non-profit who ran for who's a
conservative who uh atheist conservative
you know I think is a suicide of the
West Jonah Goldberg first line of the
book is you know there is no God he's an
arch conservative
um he had a really interesting proposal
he wanted to turn every school in the
city of Portland into a school a charter
school of choice so they all had their
missions and they could choose each yeah
each so that's what I'm talking about we
can have a compromise on this stuff
right so each parent what I'm saying is
you're taking so each parent would be
given an amount of money right and then
they could go to whatever school they
wanted to of course many on the left
went berserk and they said well how how
can you what if you want to go to a
school on the other side of a town okay
look I mean this system isn't like you
can only do what you can do right but I
think you're making my argument are you
not because my my question was what do
you think are what are sort of the red
line issues that the defunding of public
schools the the non I don't know if you
want to socialized health care but okay
so hell okay so Health you want the
government definitely involved in
healthcare and that seems to be pretty
different up to 18. yeah okay all right
but I can go for 21. right the school
one I think you're making more of the
conservative argument on school choice
well I wasn't I was bracketing the
School of Choice as a possible
compromise because the federal
government still has to go the state
government so we need to also do away
with the ZIP code idea like that this
the ZIP code urine determines the school
year absolutely Choice fun students
that's important students that's a
poison right because that guarantees you
know Bush Had No Child Left Behind that
guarantees the kids get
who are poor particularly and I don't
think it's a racial thing get trapped in
failing schools so we need to we need to
be more thoughtfully and work with
people across the aisle who hold
different opinions but those ideas you
know in the far right the extreme right
I don't even know what that means
anymore but you have people who want the
defunding if the libertarian side of the
public school system so that's two two
differences other differences abortion
for example uh but you know that's a
thorny issue I'm not sure how especially
with the new Supreme Court decisions and
state choices and so so you're obviously
pro-choice how did you feel about the
Roe v Wade decision just kicking it back
to the states where it was originally I
wasn't happy about it
um you know one of the things I do in
that those videos where I go around I
ask people I do a lot about abortion and
I'll say so they'll start on the neutral
line and I'll say abortion should be
allowed legal up to the first trimester
and they'll go from strongly agree to
strongly disagree and then I'll say
abortion should be legal and in the
second time I reset them at the neutral
line and then I'll say abortion should
be legal in the third trimester and then
I'll say I did this at Dartmouth
abortion should be legal up to the last
day
because you would see you want to see
what it takes to get people to move and
a shocking number of people will not
move up to the last day yeah so I think
that there are comp I think abortion in
the first trimester
not constitutionally protected but
federally protected would be a
compromise and then wait sorry what do
you mean by that not constitutionally
protected but well it really protected
yeah federally protected so that there
would be a legal right for women to have
an abortion in the first trimester right
so I to me what Florida has done you
know you can always bring everything
back to Florida because I really think
we're doing it so well here we have
15-week ban DeSantis sign that right the
legislature passed it before the Roe v
Wade decision came down and what's
fascinating about that was here we have
the state that is now super red it is
the leading Republican state in the
Union and it has a 15 weeks that's three
and a half months right having two kids
now I know an awful lot about that
developmental stage uh heartbeats and
all that kind of thing nobody was going
crazy over it here and this would prove
my point on the on the conservative side
the conservatives here are actually just
taking the liberal position of 25 years
ago meaning every sane liberal of 25
years ago a Bill Clinton in 19 96
liberal had some moderate position on
abortion there's going to be a cut off
it's the Democrats that went bananas
with eight-month abortions where Florida
right now again the reddest of the red
States has the 25 year ago liberal
position and that is now the answer and
I think which by the way would piss off
the most conservative I think you see
that in so many things but you know one
one thing you said that I'm thinking of
you mentioned heartbeat yeah you know
that in Hungary it's a law that you
before you get an abortion you have to
listen to the fetus's heartbeat well
isn't that interesting which according
to Stacey Abrams it's not an actual
heartbeat it's an echo of some sort of
right right but but what does that tell
you even even that right there so the
argument you're making from a from your
liberal perspective is the policy of the
most conservative place in America it
tells me with that and with censorship
you know the NWA or whatever you want to
say it that you know typagors against
the music that those policy positions
have had a large-scale shift now you've
been saying it for a long time to be a
conservative means to defend uh liberal
values yeah and
I I think that there's a profound truth
in that and that
we have far more and we're not we but
the general we have far more in common
than than people think so okay so if I
think most people watching this are
probably going all right I tend to agree
with a little more of Dave's politics
but Pete's making sense they want to
live in a country with someone like you
the same way they want to live in a
country yeah with someone like me but
what we're still dancing around I
suppose is what do you do well first off
how do we quantify how many woke people
there are and what level of power they
still have okay because that stuff is
still in the speeches
hold on hold on before we get to that I
would argue
that virtually everybody wants to live
in your America and my America because
you're in America and my America are the
same they're identical in
I would assume at least one way yeah you
want people to have Liberty I want
people to have Liberty I want people to
make their own choices and be
responsible for those choices
I believe in truth you believe in truth
we might disagree about Biden slurring
or whatever it is but we want to live in
a society that's basically has the rule
of law right I got something to eat uh
before I was coming over here and I was
walking out and some guy tried to chop
me for no reason everything in Miami
yeah do you know just right down the
block at that Supermarket down there
some guy just tried to chop me but so um
I think that your America
in my America the Americas that we're
living in have far more in common than
people think and I think that these
policy decisions those things are those
things can be worked out right we can
figure that stuff well it seems to me
that the one there are sort of slight
disagreement here is you still think
that there's a little more utility for
the state or at least at the federal
level than I do and I accept that I
would also say that if if it works
particularly with the welfare of minors
fair enough so Peter Thiel once said
something to me that that really wrong
true to me he said if he said I wouldn't
be a Libertarian if any of it worked and
I think that that maybe is the position
I'm coming from more so I like
government When government is effective
and competent and efficient that's what
we have here in Florida when you have
this other endless sucking machine that
is taking money from everyone and
resources from everyone and spending 10
billion dollars to study asexual monkeys
and their relationships to Blind frogs
there's no question and I don't know you
know one one-third of the taxes
collected in two in 2020 or 2021 yeah
2020 uh went to pay the interest on the
deficit that's insane that's insane
everybody's screaming about you know uh
sustainability that's the most
unsustainable thing and wait until the
dollar doesn't become a Global Currency
Reserve right wait till China says Hey
we'd like you to pay off our debts yeah
it's a good thing we have nukes the uh
so okay so so understanding that I think
you're right about that and by the way
uh when I did Bill Maher's podcast and
we disagreed on a whole bunch of stuff
actually more than you and I are
disagreeing out here because he's really
has this wild stuff with Trump still and
whatever what he said at the end was he
said if you and I are not within the
acceptable boundaries of what a society
could tolerate as differences of opinion
were totally screwed I mean I think
that's the right approach on that but
what do you do for the whatever amount
of people the the woke thing has
infected it continues to infect and
we're in a race it seems to be we're red
pilling people left and right I see this
happening all the time with my own
audience and I go out and to go to the
supermarket and people saying to me Dave
I didn't believe any of this stuff two
weeks ago then I saw your show I just
had that the same experience and you do
it you're literally doing it for a
living so that's all I do so but we're
out but the race is what I'm talking
about so we're we're red pilling okay
fine we're getting people to see reality
the woke thing's still infecting all of
those things as you said it it it's in
that system industry so so how do we
quantify where are we winning are we
losing our okay so we just okay so this
this is so we got to slow down
so let's talk about what the woke
control they have complete control all
the University Systems they have the DI
bureaucracy Etc they have control of
most Legacy institutions the two things
that almost nobody talks about because
almost nobody knows that they control
and the Damage they do is they control
colleges of education and Wikipedia okay
so let's break that down Okay so
I can't teach with all my Publications
years Etc doctorate Etc I can't walk in
a classroom and teach you have to get a
teaching certificate teaching
certificates in this country I'm going
to say this and this is people going to
be no way that can't possum the truth
it's solely pretty actually Peterson uh
speak spoke about this I think he's
working on something he's working on
this he's worked on this it's predicated
upon a book from a Brazilian educator
Paula Ferry the pedagogy of the
oppressed the idea is that you teach to
liberate people from you didn't say
perceive but perceive oppression as
opposed to teaching for anything else
like the truth we've educated an entire
generation of teachers pre-service
teacher education programs people going
to get their future teachers go into the
classroom and teach to demean truth and
to uphold certain non-falsifiable
ideological ideas like lived experience
lived experience trunks objective truth
Etc et cetera so that's an enormous
problem and the reason that's a problem
is even if you could take out all wokism
like you literally extricated it from
all K-12 schools it would just
repopulate because the teachers will go
back in yeah and that's the other reason
why we need to build new things like the
University of Austin is because we need
teacher training programs for people who
have not been indoctrinated into the
tenets of woke ideology okay so the
second thing that nobody talks about is
that Wikipedia is woke uh the editors of
Wikipedia oh yeah it's wild I have
people yeah and so we're going to do do
something on that that that breaks that
down and explains the Racket and the
scam it is uh you know my Wikipedia page
is consistently vandalized yeah it's
hijacked by a few people yours is as
well I've looked okay so we got those
two things
um it is it is almost impossible to
underestimate the degree that woke
infiltration has played in society in
our institutions look having spent a few
days with Elon at Twitter he knows that
there were bad actors yeah he called it
a giant crime scene yeah and it was a
giant I just spoke to Michael Shelton
yeah we just you know it was a giant
crime scene and the idea is that woke
people
they you know they get indoctrinated
into the school system they go out from
from uh well it starts in K-12 because
again their teachers get teaching
certificates that are indoctrinated they
go through college they then because
they have the college degree go into
positions of authority in the society
and then slowly but surely the
terminology comes in uh safe spaces
micro aggressions trigger warnings
inclusion is a huge one nobody talks
about anymore very few people talk about
they have infiltrated virtually every
industry economy uh of of
um every they've infiltrated the
military they've entered for treated the
Biden with the government uh they've
interpretated the southern baptist
they've infiltrated the Catholic church
so the question is
what do we do about it and I I have a
whole set of prescriptions that we get
so okay so there's the build new things
version of it there's there's the argue
with people to show them the light sort
of thing and I'm not argue with them but
ask them assist a talk Community with
them communicate sorry so but I'm still
curious about this thing do you think we
can outrun it do you think that this
parasite that has that has overtaken so
many hosts as I always describe it you
know the alien in the ship killing
everybody and and the doctor likes it in
the original alien because he's like
it's merciless it's doing exactly what
it wants you got to give it credit he
feels a a camaraderie with it because it
is so focused and it's accomplishing
what it wants to accomplish do you think
we can outrun it even even if we have an
entire generation of young people coming
behind us that are going to be more
energetic than us it's not sustainable
yeah it's and I'll tell you why it's not
sustainable it has no by design it has
no apologetic it has no defense but
built into it woke people don't know the
other side of the argument by Design
because it's platforming it's Nazism
they won't read it they won't look at it
it's
even even you know not even things like
gender studies but there is no debate
there is no conversation and when you
take debate and conversation out of it
you just go ever further down into into
a uh into a rabbit hole but just
recently last few days in The Chronicle
of Higher Ed that had pieces coming out
even the New York Times which is the
walkest of them all I think they hired
McWhorter to kind of save their image
Etc but uh you see now people starting
to question people starting to challenge
people speaking openly about it and
unfortunately they're doing it in the
most superficial manifestation which is
cancel culture right I mean so what do
we do what what do we do about the fact
that we have ideological capture of our
main institutions well let's talk about
what the problem with that is first the
problem is that those institutions don't
have any legitimacy you don't Harbor
call this the legitimation crisis
there's a crisis religion a lot of
people I've been screaming about this
for years nobody listens but the reason
for that is they don't have legitimacy
because they're not legitimate so people
don't trust them so we that's why to
bring it back to what I said at the
beginning of the show we need something
we can rely on we need some gold
standard something that universally
aligns us politically socially morally
and that should be the peer review
process if something gets stamped as
peer review we can say the best Minds
have tried to falsify it experts in the
fields have tried to look at it and I
also want to say one more thing yeah but
you accept that the inherent problem is
that the woke will never accept that
because they will say it is an old right
that's why we need to destroy it we need
to build new things that's also why we
need ideological diversity you know
people will say well why should I trust
the science on the science they'll put
in quotation marks on global climate
change anthropogenic warming if the
university is staffed with 99 Ultra
leftist well they're right yeah that's
uh that's absolutely right I mean that's
why when the Supreme Court is balanced
you know 5'4 sure liberals may be a far
right or far left or that's why people
are more likely to trust those decisions
so ideological diversity confers a kind
of legitimation on a system it
legitimizes the system in a way that uh
simply saying it's legitimate or have
good branding or now the New York Times
is bad branding well it was all the news
that fit to print now it's all the
propaganda but now it's been ideological
clu splc things we used to trust for
hate groups for example we can't trust
those and I will tell you to repeat it
again one of the biggest problems that
nobody's talking about is Wikipedia yeah
well it is a problem I wonder where is
it being then used that it matters so
like I gave up years ago trying to
contact them and try to correct there's
no point to it it's just pointless it's
just pointless but where is it being
used that it matters like does it matter
that much like you think because people
are actually trying to find out about
people oh it's interesting it's so so
I'm even hesitant to say this because
now this people who are doing this to me
are going to double down on it but you
know that I so I I don't even know how
many books I've written the forward to
I've written the four to a lot of books
I just wrote the forward to Rajiv
Malhotra snakes in the ganga I've
written before to John loftus's book
I've been from the Lizzy's book tons of
forts but I wrote the forward to Dan
Arrow's book who's now woke Maniac uh I
wrote I wrote the forward to Stefan
molyneux book Against The Gods it was
about agnosticism and if all the
forwards I wrote it's in there that's
the one and it's like not only that he
wrote the forward to white supremacist
stefanimal as if
you know I'm somehow in long-term
standing collaborative relationship is
if I'm in some kind of Cahoots with the
white supremacists to talk about whites
you know the superior race but but those
things are incredibly damaged because
they're bundled with the software when
you get them they're bundled with
browsers there and so when people want
to learn about something quickly they go
to Wikipedia they're 50 at it we could
this is a whole nother show yeah they're
the way that those decisions get made uh
the guy who edits my page is openly
antifa it's interesting because I think
you could probably and this is what what
uh Elon was saying about a crime scene
yeah you can probably make the same
argument for almost every big tech
company that there is there was a while
where there they were I was being doxxed
on Reddit and and horrible things were
happening on there I contacted someone
extremely high up at Reddit like BP
level and they basically were like you
have to submit a support ticket right
and I was like well I'm being doxed I
could have someone show up at my house
and kill me these are people who are
obsessively hating on me blah blah blah
correct well you have to and I do the
ticket nothing comes of it and it's like
you guys it's as if the system is
designed to let the worst ideas flourish
yeah
it's designed to let a small group of
radical activists
who encourage violence who really
there's no polite way to say it you know
I I they're just dyspeptic malcontents
and they I don't know what these people
do they must have no lives and no jobs
and all they do is hate like I see the
stuff on Reddit like about they go crazy
on you they go crazy on me they're going
crazy on everybody so that's the thing
that I think they've helped the
trajectory honestly and they've oh well
I think they've also helped me like
first off at this point I just don't
care but it never stopped me and if
anything it was it was fueling my my
desire for success and I didn't realize
it when it used to bother me now it's
just like all right keep going yeah okay
so that's true I also think it's funny
sort of like you're waking up like Dave
rubin's the biggest problem yeah okay so
here so here's my my first so I think
you're in another level then I remember
when we were walking when we got ice
cream do we need is we are we no we're
good we're good you remember when we got
ice cream and when that was my look
we're going to continue because he's
doing okay this time oh okay this is 50
50 yeah okay you know yes we were
getting ice cream I remember the Twitter
eggs with my sign and you said if a guy
came up to you with a Twitter egg right
now he started screaming at you yeah you
remember that and I really thought about
like that was a like really you know why
should you wait just to be clear we were
walking down the street going to get ice
cream with your son and we were talking
about this like endless hatred that
people get online and I was saying how
someone across the street just started
screaming Pete bagosian is a f and blah
blah blah you would just keep walking
wouldn't walk up to them and engage them
and spend time with them and all of
those things right you would just keep
walking but for some reason there was
this need for people to do it online
with the anonymity as a cloak and so my
fear so two things my fear is always
been that uh I've got something wrong
and the way that I can figure out if
I've got something wrong is to listen to
dissenting voices is to listen to say
which they're going to use that against
and that's what I said on your show last
time I think I missed a word but the
most important thing is you have to
figure out whose voice doesn't matter
like if you like when you like this is a
great example like this brings it back
to what we talked about are you drunk
tweeting right now yeah like so you when
you tell me something like okay Dave
Reuben said that you know if Dawkins
contacts me like I'd be okay now I've
got to stop and think about this but if
it's a random person you don't there's
no point to even looking at it right but
I do think that there is that that there
is something if I could give advice to
if I give advice on where I looked
advice if I give advice to you you have
to figure out whose voice doesn't matter
and if you have if you're being mobbed
on social media or people are freaking
out at you like so what like it's just
this too shall pass like it's just it's
just people who have way too much time
oh on their hands you know the other
thing I've learned going around the
world asking people questions like
political questions or controversial
questions is
when you leave the United States
people are not looking for a reason to
be offended in the United States
particularly in college campuses they
are hungry to be offended they are
craving offense they want to show what a
good person they are what a decent
person what a virtuous person they are
by how outraged they are that someone's
on a different line or has a difference
of opinion from them I mean you seem to
have done a far better job of getting
like I you did it more quickly I'm
slowly at that point
um but I have not you mean getting over
there I arrived yeah of just well I also
think if you don't give them what they
want which at some point when I just was
like I'm never responding to these
people I'm never paying attention I'm
not giving it a moment of my public or
private time at some point they just
start running out of fuel because what
they also want is the reaction right
there is nothing that makes you know one
of these nihilistic 100 that's the other
thing they already hate you yeah they
short of you groveling which would make
them hate you more right there's
literally nothing you can say and I
already hate you the irony and I
absolutely know this is true of you is
if someone came to me if someone sent me
a thoughtful email saying and by the way
I get something like this every now and
again you know Dave actually you were
talking about taxes and this and that
and I disagree with you on this here's
one I will address it I like it we do a
post game show on my show now where I'm
I'm trying to get people to correct me
right genuinely if I screwed something
up I was but that's different than the
the nihilistic destruction Integrity
yeah right that's called integrity
speaking of Integrity Pete this is the
last time you can do the show this is it
I'm no longer a friend of the show I'm
thrown off I've known an enemy of the
show do you have anything else you'd
like to say a man of great integrity uh
you saw Nancy Pelosi after Biden's
speech he did she said he's a wonder she
does this weird thing with her hands now
too he's a wonderful man an aspirational
man
I saw Chris Christie too and again he
didn't wasn't talking about the dementia
thing or whatever uh anything else I'd
like to say
um
go ahead I got one over here I'm going
to give you a great out anything you
want no I had something because you can
go with that one too but I all right I
have one more question for you and then
I'll let you give him a closing say my
question for you is this
being here in Florida yeah taking this
entire conversation that we've had yeah
the beautiful weather the freedom a
system that's working right flourishing
getting rid of all the things that
you're frustrated with right could a
good liberal like you
vote for a guy like Ron DeSantis
who's he running against
he's running against Joe Biden or he's
running against Kamal Ayers for the
president Gavin Newsom yeah okay you
name two of those three people I I have
very serious problems with
um it seems to me he is the guy
addressing more of the issues than that
you're talking about than anyone else
yeah so in defending people's ability to
live freely so here's what I would do so
I would
rather than just capriciously answer it
the the serious you're looking at me
like come on man no I'm telling you I
would look at what his positions are the
answer to your question is yes but
before I gave that yes I would look at
what his positions were and I would
balance those out against the person
against you you know he was running
against and then but yeah I see no
reason why I wouldn't vote for a
republican if they had more
evidence-based positions for sure
is that fair you couched it like a
liberal but I accept that okay I'll take
that as a and now I give you open floor
to end this properly the way you wanted
to end it
uh I want to come back to something we
said at the beginning if you have a
disagreement with somebody then you just
text them and tell them you have a
disagreement with them like you it's
it's completely fine that you and I
would have a disagreement about abortion
or DeSantis or even things closer to our
own heart you know
and you know if you told me listen you
know you're uh I I would have a problem
with it but I would I would have a
problem with it within the context of
our conversation if you should listen I
think the fact that you've adopted a
Chinese uh girl is an interracial
kidnapping okay so we that okay we we
would have a conversation that might be
a bridge well no it would hurt me I
would I'd feel hurt but the fact that is
you yes that also I'd also yeah I'd also
want to know why you thought that right
and also but I think letting friends be
wrong is one of the most important
lessons that we can have and and I also
think it makes your life more
interesting and you have more spirited
disagreements with the people you know
Aristotle talks about that in the ethics
he said the highest form of friendship
is between two virtuous people I thought
about that for decades since I've read
that like somebody you know you can come
to me and I can come to you if if I
think you're off base I will I
absolutely tell you off yes and I think
we've had those conversations before
you've told that to me those are the
kind of friendships you should strive to
have as opposed to everybody agreeing
with everyone until you disagree about
one small thing and then everyone's a
Nazi you want to go get drunk and fight
some random people I want to know about
the latter but maybe the former
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about Academia
check out our Academia playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell